MALE SPEAKER: We're
here with Josh Weltman.
So Josh is a 25-year veteran
of the advertising business,
a working creative director,
a co-producer, a writer,
and an artist.
He's a real-life "Mad Men."
He's created commercials
and ad campaigns
for Taco Bell, Doritos, Carls
Jr., BMW, Earthlink, Microsoft,
Whole Foods, Green
Burrito, and Cuties.
He's authored everything from
online guerrilla marketing
efforts for small clients
to national campaigns
for global automotive
companies like Kia Motors.
Josh has been part of "Mad
Men" since its first season.
He worked closely with Matt
Weiner and the show's writers
and producers to ensure that
"Mad Men" accurately depicted
the process of creating
ads and servicing clients.
He also created most of the
original ads seen in the show.
Josh's first book,
"Seducing Strangers:
The Little Black Book
of Advertising Secrets"
is a great read.
We have them here
for sale today,
and we're going to be talking
about that for the first part
of interview.
We'll talk about the
show for a little bit
and then turn it
over to you guys
for all your
wonderful questions.
So here we go.
JOSH WELTMAN: All right.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm going to
begin with the question, OK?
The biggest one.
It's all downhill from here.
JOSH WELTMAN: How
does it end, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
JOSH WELTMAN: How
does "Mad Men" end?
MALE SPEAKER: That's a good one.
JOSH WELTMAN: I can't tell you.
MALE SPEAKER: Trying to
do no spoilers today.
What is happiness?
We talk about it with
each other all the time.
We ask ourselves the question.
I'm sitting here with an ad man.
What is happiness?
JOSH WELTMAN: I think
happiness-- let's see,
I wrote it down.
Happiness is when reality
meets or exceeds expectations.
That's what I
think happiness is.
MALE SPEAKER: That's it.
JOSH WELTMAN: I think
that's pretty good.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Does it matter what we
have or what we don't have
in terms of happiness, or--
JOSH WELTMAN: I don't think
what we have or don't have makes
as big a difference as what
we have or don't have-- well,
of course, after
basic needs are met,
what makes a lot of difference
is what we have or don't have
vis a vis what we
expect to have.
That sort of thing.
I think people-- I think
that's what makes people happy.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So as a marketer, how
you go actually go about,
I guess, managing expectations,
setting expectations?
What's that process like?
JOSH WELTMAN: Well, I think that
the process from an advertising
point of view is to
try and figure out
what it is your
prospect wants, and then
figure out how your products
can deliver on that.
You know, what do they
expect from their life?
What do they expect from
the things they buy?
What do they expect from an
experience with your company
or brand?
And then figure out if your
products and services are
in line with your
customers' expectations,
and what needs to
change to bring them
into alignment, either their
expectations or your products
and services.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So is that a-- is that an
explicit thing that gets
discussed around the table?
You know, like we need to
set people's expectations
different?
Or is it more of a subtle
skill that really great ad men,
ad women have?
JOSH WELTMAN: I think
that's most of the meetings
that I attended were about.
I remember one campaign that
is actually still running.
I worked on it
maybe 15 years ago.
It was a campaign for
hamburgers called Carl's Jr.
And at the time, when we
first picked up the project,
the burgers were known
as big sloppy messes that
were as close to a mistake
as you could ever receive
from a drive-through window.
I mean, there was stuff
coming out of them,
and lettuce and
things like that.
And they were kind
of a disaster.
And then we went in and talked
to focus groups about what
people wanted from a hamburger.
And we were talking
specifically to 18-
to 34-year-old men who had
between $4.00 and $6.00
to spend at lunch every day.
And they tended to be working
people, and hungry people,
and every one of them, every one
of these groups that we taped,
these guys would
be sitting around,
and they'd start talking
about the burger that
made them happy.
And they'd be making this
gesture, like, they'd
turn into these animals.
And they'd talk about it's
drippy, it's like bloody
and stuff like that.
And when we took the
tape to the client,
we turned the sound off
because we said, you know,
you're creating these ads
now that talk about how clean
the restaurant is and how
decent the ingredients are.
And you're trying to
satisfy that animal
that you see on the screen
that's doing-- this caveman
kind of guy.
And we said, we're not
gong to change the product.
That thing that we've
been delivering,
that messy in the
bag, they want that.
What we're going to do is we're
going to start promising that
to them, because
what was out of whack
was the customer's desire was
not in line with the promise
that the company was
making about their product.
They had the product.
They had exactly
what they wanted,
this big, messy, drippy thing.
And so instead of
changing it, we
recognized we started speaking
the language of the people who
were hungry.
MALE SPEAKER: Made them
happy in the process.
JOSH WELTMAN: Made them
really happy in the process,
made the company
over in the process,
made the owners of the
company really happy.
A lot of people got happy.
MALE SPEAKER: That's good stuff.
You're in the business
of making people happy.
I like it.
All right, another big
definition question.
The book is called
"Seducing Strangers."
JOSH WELTMAN: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: What is seduction?
JOSH WELTMAN: I think
seduction is figuring out
what people want to
hear about themselves
and telling them just
that, that you figure out
what people are itching for,
and basically you scratch it.
That's seducing.
MALE SPEAKER: Telling people
what they want to hear.
JOSH WELTMAN: Telling people
If you want to
know how to seduce,
I think that's how you do it.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
How does this apply
in advertising?
How does this work
in the real world?
JOSH WELTMAN: I
don't particularly
know how it works
in the real world.
I'm not good at it one on one.
I'm very bad at it one
on one, because I'm not
the type of person
that's willing to change
who I am to be satisfying or
to make other people happy,
personally.
But I seem to have a really
good talent for figuring out
what large groups of people
want to hear about themselves
and being able to tell stories
that they can see themselves
in, that satisfy them.
So it depends on what
part of the real world
you're talking about.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's
talk about advertising.
We talked about
making people happy.
Now we're talking about
affirming people as they are.
Can you talk about an
ad you've worked on
or a story in advertising
that reflects that?
JOSH WELTMAN: That
affirms what people--
MALE SPEAKER:
Well, you're saying
seduction is telling people
what they want to hear.
How to ads do that,
is my question.
JOSH WELTMAN: Well--
MALE SPEAKER: Or I could have
a salad, is what I'm saying.
JOSH WELTMAN: Well,
that's actually a good one
to talk about, because that
one worked counter intuitively.
I worked on a product-- I
don't know if anyone's ever
been to Green Burrito.
It was really not
ready to be advertised.
But contractually, we had to.
And it's a long story.
So a bunch of us from the agency
went to try out the product.
And it was a sort of a fast
food Mexican type thing.
And we went there and were
completely disappointed.
A lot of things were
made using a microwave,
and this sort of thing.
And at the time we said, take
your million-dollar ad budget
and work on your menu.
Get it ready to-- because
there's an old advertising
adage, nothing will kill a
bad product quicker than good
advertising.
You make people come in.
They try it, they'll
be disappointed,
you'll never see them again.
But the client was
insisting that they
wanted to spend their
million dollars, which
was about 1/14th of what
the other big Mexican food
player in the market
was spending annually,
so they were outspent 14 to one.
They didn't have a
very good product.
But still they said, can
you do something for us?
We really want to advertise.
OK.
We came up with a little singing
green dot in a black field.
And the little dot
would say things like,
if it's green it's good.
If it's bluish green,
you're going to need shots.
And then it would cut to the
logo and say, Green Burrito.
If it's green, it's good.
And one of the
other ads, I think,
said, if you get guacamole on
a green burrito, it's good.
If you get guacamole on your
lip, it looks like boogers.
Green burrito.
It's good.
So anyhow, what
we did was we said
that the food is so bad that
by talking about gangrene
and boogers we could lower
expectations to a level
that your products may be
able to meet or exceed.
And that was the only
thing that we could really
recommend the client
do in good conscience.
And we did, and they did it.
And it kind of worked.
Not a lot of people went to
the restaurant for that year,
but they all knew the
little talking dot.
They were very-- you know,
the audience knew that.
As a matter of fact,
I think after spending
a million dollars
that year, the company
had achieved parity awareness
with the other company,
the competitor that was
spending $14 million.
So we had achieved awareness.
We hadn't set anybody's
expectations really high.
And we solved the problem.
But that's sort of a
counter intuitive, lower
the bar kind of success story.
MALE SPEAKER: Look, the
question was about seduction.
The takeaway about
seduction is gangrene--
JOSH WELTMAN: Being seduced
with gangrene and boogers.
MALE SPEAKER:
Gangrene and boogers.
OK.
Seduction.
JOSH WELTMAN: Seduction.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So I want to talk
a little bit just
about some of the specifics in
the book. f A couple of quotes
from the book.
"Advertising is not about
changing the audience's beliefs
or the things that drive them.
It's about confirming them.
Nobody needs to lie about
how rewarding a product is
or isn't.
You just need to
remind people who
feel they deserve a reward
that they're absolute right
to feel this way."
And then my favorite,
"It's mostly
about persuading people to do
a little more of what they're
already doing.
The money is in telling
people they're right,
and to keep doing what
they're doing, preferably
with your particular brand,
product, or service in mind."
So I think the obvious
question there,
what if what people think, do,
feel, and believe is wrong,
or it's harmful to them?
How do you respond to
questions about, I guess,
the moral compass
you have when you
are trying to get people to do
something one way or another?
JOSH WELTMAN: Let's see.
OK.
Let's just go with the
one we've been talking
about for the last 20 minutes,
which is getting people
to eat hamburgers
and bad Mexican food,
which I spent a lot
of my career doing.
What we talked about
before is, most of the time
I'm not the dumbest
person in the room.
Sometimes, a lot
of the times, I'm
not the smartest
person in the room.
But I do know when
lunchtime comes around,
I like to choose what
I want to choose.
I don't particularly feel like
the smartest person in the room
should be choosing what they
think I should eat for lunch.
I think what I said when
we were talking beforehand
is, I understand why society
has laws that protect people
from products that are
dangerous to society
under the best of circumstances.
But I don't particularly think
we need laws or regulations
that protect individuals
from risky products,
products that are risky under
the worst circumstances.
I think that's what being an
individual is about evaluating.
So I don't think it's
about lying or deceiving.
I think it's the difference
between products or things
that are always
dangerous to everybody
versus things that can sometimes
be dangerous to individuals.
I think those things have
to be looked at differently.
Does that answer the question?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
I think it does.
OK.
Very good.
Just one or two more questions
about advertising before we
talk about the show.
What are emthymemes?
That was interesting.
And how does it work with
our dopamine, our adrenaline?
I'd be curious to
hear more about that.
JOSH WELTMAN: There's a section
in the book where I talk
about a thing called enthymeme.
And an enthymene is a thing
that Aristotle refers to
in a book called "Rhetoric."
And it's basically--
the translation
is "within the mind."
And when I was about 25,
I was reading this book
while taking my first
class in advertising
and learning how to come up with
concepts that were intriguing
and arresting to people.
And I came across
this line that said,
when using this enthymeme
technique to try and engage
somebody, here's how it works.
The first part of
the phrase confuses--
if the first part of the phrase
confuses, the second part
explains.
If the first part explains,
the second part confuses.
And this discord, people
trying to figure this out,
is what engages their mind
in a speaker's argument.
And the example
I use in the book
is that Samuel Johnson
could have said,
there are a lot of things
to do or see in London.
But what he said was, when
a man is tired of London,
he's tired of life.
And the first part sort of
confuses, and the second part
explains.
And you're engaged as you
go through the beginning
of this thing to the
end of the thing.
And I think that modern
advertising sort of
started in the mid
'60s when someone
discovered that if
the picture confuses,
the headline explains.
And if the headline confuses,
the picture explains.
And using images and words
together in this fashion
is sort of a modern
enthymeme to engage people
in an image that was used
to stop them from flipping
through a magazine, get them
interested in a television
commercial, make them stare
at a poster on the street.
But this technique has been
being used for the last 40
years to engage people's heads.
MALE SPEAKER: It's interesting.
We were talking about
the way Aristotle
mentions it's rhetoric.
This enthymeme gets you
to listen to a speaker
or to get more tuned into
what the speaker's saying.
I was thinking about a magazine.
Endless pages, you're
flipping, you're
seeing a lot of
stuff you expect,
articles, images, words
trying to sell things to you.
And I remember a classic
ad I think they referred to
in the show is a Volkswagen
ad for, I think, the Beetle.
It's a tiny little car
on this big white page.
The ad itself is very small.
It's a lot of wasted space.
And I think the tagline
is, think small.
Is that what you're
talking about?
JOSH WELTMAN: Yeah, exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: It confuses
you, catches your attention.
JOSH WELTMAN: Imagine, we
talked about on the show.
You're flipping through
this magazine circa 1961,
and you come across this
big, empty white page
with a little teeny car.
And your head is
going, what is this?
This is not-- this
should not be here.
This is confusing.
What are they trying to say?
Is this a mistake?
Where's the rest of the
stuff that goes on the page?
Oh, think small.
I get it.
I'm engaged.
I see that they're
trying to say that it's
about being different, or being
unexpected, or being unique,
or whatever that is.
But for that
fraction of a second,
when somebody's trying to
resolve that confusion,
you have an opportunity as a
seller of goods and services
to engage them in a discussion.
They're open because they're
trying to figure something out.
MALE SPEAKER: I think you
also-- last thing on this point.
You mentioned adrenaline
and dopamine specifically
get released in this process.
JOSH WELTMAN: Yeah, sure.
I mean, what your head is doing.
I don't know, but I've read
articles like everybody else.
I'm not doctor, but--
when you're confused,
it's that fight or flight.
You know, you're trying
to figure it out.
And then when the tumblers
fall in your mind,
you feel that reward.
I've felt it trying
to come up with ideas.
I know when I've
solved the puzzle
and what that feels like.
And I think that
it's the combination
of chemicals that make you
feel that way going off
in your head.
That's the reason that an
enthymeme, literally translated
from Greek, means "in
your mind," you know.
It's happening in your head.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's
talk about "Mad Men."
So for those of you
watching on YouTube,
we took a quick look at a clip.
I think it's Episode 13,
Season 1, "The Carousel."
Feel free to look it up.
We're going to talk
about that a little bit.
I'd love to know-- I'm
sure a lot of folks
here too as well-- how
were these pitches created
for the show?
What was the process?
Could you walk us through that?
JOSH WELTMAN: One of the
things Matt Weiner-- if you're
familiar with the show, Matt
Weiner is the showrunner.
The person who
invented "Mad Men"
is a stickler for accuracy.
And early on we were friends--
or we're still friends,
but we were just friends before
he had a show on television.
And he was talking
about advertising,
and we said, to be accurate
about creating ads,
ads are created in the agency
environment, at that time
a team of an art
director working
with a writer, the
pictures and the words
working together to come
up with a concept the way I
was just describing.
Typically, shows based
in the advertising world,
or movies based in
the advertising world,
before "Mad Men," a writer
would write the script
and they'd march the script
down to the art department,
and the art department
would make up the ad the way
they make up any other prop.
And that's how you
got advertising.
And Matt recognized
that we would probably
get more accurate ads if the
writer's room began working
the way real agencies did.
And I'm an art
director by background,
and he brought me
in one day a week
to work on the business
stories and the concept
for ads with the writers
as they happened.
And that's how--
MALE SPEAKER: Could you
walk us through, maybe,
how "The Carousel" came about?
JOSH WELTMAN: At
the end of Season 1,
the main character,
Don Draper, has
had-- his marriage
is breaking up,
his business is falling
apart, his brother
has just committed suicide.
And Matt said, we need a
business story or a product
that explains, lets
the audience see
what Don is feeling
about his marriage,
his business, his
brother's suicide.
And that's sort of
a tough-- I'm not
sure there are a lot
of products like that.
But one of the
things that I used
to do before going
into the writer's room
to work with the
writers and stuff
is, I would leaf through the
PDFs of "The New York Times"
advertising section of the
week that the story on the show
was taking place.
And so I'd go-- it
was October of 1961.
I'd read the advertising
column in "The New York Times."
And I noticed that Kodak was
working on a slide projector,
or there was something,
and I checked and saw
that it came out the next year.
It was called the carousel.
I figured whatever they were
doing at the time in real life
was probably happening
about that time,
with a year kind of thing.
And I remember my father--
in the '60s, cameras and film
and Super 8 cameras
and hi-fi equipment.
They were the high tech
gadgets of their time.
And these guys like Don
Draper spent a lot of time
with photographic equipment,
single lens reflex cameras,
all that sort of thing.
And I thought maybe he
did what my dad did,
which is have a bunch of
slides of trips in the closet,
and sort through them.
And if we could use
some of his slides
from his life in
a pitch, we could
understand what he was
feeling about his business,
his marriage, his
life in general.
And so that's what
we brought in.
We probably could have
done the same thing
if the product had been a Super
8 movie camera or something
like that, anything
where he could've
used his own images in the
sales pitch to the client.
But the slide projector
worked really well.
MALE SPEAKER: So one of
the tag lines for the show
is "Where the truth lies."
And you write that the main
insight into Don's character,
and the most important
conceit of the show,
is that Don Draper can lie
anywhere except in advertising.
And why is that?
JOSH WELTMAN: He's lying to his
wife, he's lying to his kids,
he's lying to his partner--
he lies to everybody,
he lies to himself.
But it was very
important to Matt Weiner
that Don, as the main
character, be good at his job.
He thought that
the audience needed
him to be good at
something, to respect him
on some level, or else all this
other stuff that he was doing,
that no one would stick with it.
It was just too dark.
And so I felt that
what we were looking at
was a guy who
could lie anywhere,
except in the advertising.
In the advertising, he's basing
his work on truthful insights
that he has into people.
He obviously understands what
makes people tick very well,
or he couldn't write good ads.
And that makes his own
kind of internal struggle
to understand what's motivating
him, and what makes him tick,
even more poignant.
MALE SPEAKER: So I wonder, are
there Don Drapers out there?
Were there, are
there people who just
walk into a pitch
like that and just--
JOSH WELTMAN: And kill?
Yeah, sure.
Not as often and
consistently as a guy
who's working in
front of clients,
who will do exactly what
12 smart writers tell
the clients to do.
But yeah, he's kind
of based on an amalgam
of people who are really
good salesmen, who
understand how people tick.
MALE SPEAKER: He's a composite.
JOSH WELTMAN: Oh sure, yeah.
I mean, there's 30
different writers
working in the writers'
room since the beginning
of the show.
They all bring different
experiences to Don.
And there's all sorts of
different stories about ad men
that me and Bob Levinson, the
other advertising consultant,
would bring into the room.
There's all sorts of books about
different advertising people
that all the writers
were expected to read.
Matt had done
extensive research.
People knew what good
salesmen were like.
And we just took whatever
worked and created,
like, Frankenstein,
the ultimate ad guy,
bits and pieces from everywhere.
MALE SPEAKER: So one
of my favorite comments
about the show-- I think it was
the week of the last episode--
so Matt Weiner was
being interviewed,
and he said that the show "Mad
Men" is about what people want,
what they can get, and how
happiness lies somewhere
in between.
And it reminded me of what you
talked about happiness being,
as this different
expectation reality.
Could you talk about that
in relation to the show?
JOSH WELTMAN: Yeah, I think
that's what the story is about.
I think it's about trying to
bridge that gap between a man's
expectations and his reality.
And every story is
the story of how
someone got something,
or didn't get something
that they desired.
And that's what we're
watching, or that's
what we watched, over the course
of eight seasons of "Mad Men."
How does he get the
life he thinks he wants?
Or how does he get what
makes him feel happy?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I've
got questions for days,
but I'd love to take
some from the audience
if you guys are curious at all.
There's Mike, right
in the middle.
MIKE: I'll ask one.
So my question is, would you
see advertising in utopia?
And so going back to that
expectation around advertising,
could we see the explosion
of ways of advertising
as a barometer for getting
farther from utopia?
JOSH WELTMAN: OK.
Would there be
advertising in utopia?
You mean, where everybody's
happy, do we need--
MIKE: There's no expectation.
JOSH WELTMAN: There's no
expect-- I don't know.
It's a tough one.
I was thinking
about that, kind of,
when I saw
"Tomorrowland" come out,
because I think that what's
missing a lot from people's
lives today are basically
somebody's vision of where
we should be heading.
It sounds cute that, when you
think of Walt Disney building
Tomorrowland, and
when I was little,
how you'd go to the
Monsanto exhibit
of the kitchen of tomorrow
and all that sort of stuff.
And it was kind of
funky, but it made
you feel good that we
were heading somewhere,
you know, that those
expectations were--
they may be right, they may be
wrong, they may be whatever.
But they were shared
by so many people.
And we had this
idea that we were
all kind of heading
towards this one direction.
And I think that people's
vision of the future,
and their expectation
is so fragmented,
it doesn't feel like
there's any one person
or group of visionary
thinkers who are saying,
yeah, maybe let's get together
for the World's Fair of 2018
and lay out where we're going.
So I don't know if that
answers the question or not.
But yeah, I think you
really do need expectations.
And I think the angst going
on today, or part of it,
is that people don't
know where we're heading.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so when
you talk about Don Draper
as a profile of an ideal
"Mad Men" in his time, two
questions.
How did you put
yourself in that era?
Was there much of an adjustment?
And secondly, what is
the profile of today,
and how might be different?
Do we value different things
than a successful advertising
person?
JOSH WELTMAN: In a persuader?
I don't even think we
call them successful
advertising people anymore.
You know, because
advertising is sort of
in such a state of
transition and flux,
it's hard to think of what
makes advertising successful
nowadays.
And it's hard to
think of someone
who feels successful doing it.
I had a friend say, maybe six
months ago-- a seasoned ad
person, a very good writer
and good at his job--
and he was talking and
lamenting the place
that he worked spends a
lot of time sort of talking
about creating
experiences rather
than tools of persuasion.
And he said, we used to
make tools for clients,
and now we make toys.
We used to really
think about what
the messages that
we were making,
what they were
supposed to do, what
the payoff was supposed to be.
I talk a lot about
that in the book,
because with each of those
four different types of ads,
there's a different
metric involved.
And you knew what you
were trying to do,
and you knew if you
were making progress.
Yeah that one, I
really didn't think
things had changed a lot between
when I was working even 2010.
And I'll tell you the big moment
that was really different.
I remember in 1989, when the
big advertising conglomerate
that I was working for
sent out a memo that
said they were no longer going
to expense liquor at lunch.
And one of the old
copywriters, really
genius guy who'd been doing
it for a long, long time,
came and sat down in my office.
And I was the young
20-something guy,
and he was-- really
had been doing it
since like the '40s or '50s
at least, but just a genius.
And he says, that's it.
That's the end of this.
I'll tell you how
he meant it, but he
said, what kind of person
would approve this stuff sober,
you know?
And he didn't mean that the
account guys were getting
the clients drunk at lunch
to try and pull something
over on them.
But he was trying to
say, look, when you're
trying to do something edgy
or exciting or engaging,
or something that
can't be rationalized
in a cost-benefit
type of way, you've
got to make these
guys brave, you know?
And that's what the liquor did.
And after that, people
were much more tentative,
and sort of-- I never I heard
the phrase "risk averse"
until they said they weren't
going to expense liquor
at lunch.
I'll just put it that way.
Yeah.
JOHN: How you doing?
I'm John.
I'm from the YouTube
marketing team.
And I gotta say, "Mad Men" is
as much a case study for us,
in some respects, as it
is like an episodic thing.
We talk about it a lot at work,
and a lot of fans at YouTube
and I know Google wide.
My question was, I was
hoping you could help me
kind of sort through a
moral dilemma I sometimes
think about when it
comes to marketing.
And I talk about
this with friends
who are on the agency side
and go through this as well.
And I wonder, what do
you think about how
advertising and
the need for it had
led to materialism and
consumerism in the world today?
Like I feel like a lot
of us tend to buy things
that maybe we don't need.
And being in marketing and
having friends in advertising,
sometimes we think about,
are we pushing messages
that we don't believe in?
Are we selling products that
maybe people don't need?
And--
JOSH WELTMAN: No, I
know what you're asking.
MALE SPEAKER: You should
tell the Taco Bell story
while you're trying to say that.
JOSH WELTMAN: No, the first day
that I went into the writers'
room on "Mad Men,"
I remember I brought
in three pieces of paper.
They're now hanging
in the Museum
of Moving Images in New York
with the set-- or not the set,
the whole writers' room has
moved there-- but on one
of them it said, "Scary.
There are big corporations out
there that are-- what was it?
It's scary.
There are big
corporations out there
who are controlling what
you think and what you feel
and making you buy things
that leave you broke
and feeling empty.
And then it said, scarier.
There are no big
corporations out
there controlling
what you think, feel,
and making you buy things
that leave you broke
and feeling empty, that
it's kind of in your head.
I think that people
believe that they can make
their life better, you know.
I don't think I put
that belief there.
I don't think you put
I think that's the
human condition, that we
believe things can be better.
I think that the problem
is that we think things
that we buy-- we think
that better can be bought.
And usually, it can't be.
You gotta sort of
look at who you are
and what you're asking
for and those sort
of things kind of thing.
So I don't think that the
desire to make your life better
is something that's instilled--
that's caused consumerism.
I think that what causes
consumerism is thinking
that stuff that you can consume
will make you feel better
about life.
And that's not what-- the
advertisers aren't planting
that thought in people.
There's a lot of reasons that
I think that that exists.
And it's about people finding
what truly makes them happy,
and not the stuff
that's being advertised,
or how it will make them happy.
JOHN: I'm just curious
as, like, a follow up.
Do you why, or do
you have a thought
as to why consumerism is higher
today than it was before?
JOSH WELTMAN: I mean,
consumerism of some things
are-- what specifically?
Because I don't know-- I think
there's more people with-- you
know, like when I
was coming up, China
was not consuming the same sort
of things that they are now.
But I know the stuff
that they were consuming
wasn't making them
particularly happy.
They wanted to
have what you have.
They wanted cars and
city life and choices,
and the supermarket
and stuff like that.
So they think they're
consuming stuff
for the same reason you do.
They think this stuff
will make you happy.
Maybe it will,
maybe-- I don't know.
The more dissatisfied
with the stuff
we got, we try and improve it
and get new stuff, I think.
JOHN: Thank you.
JOSH WELTMAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So storytelling
is very in vogue today
in business and speaking.
Can you take us to where your
vision is on storytelling
the next 10 years?
What should we be
thinking about?
Or is it really the same
from Don Draper's time today
and tomorrow?
JOSH WELTMAN: I think that
a lot of the difference
between the industrial economy
and the knowledge economy
is that in the industrial
economy, managers that
could manage things that could
be measured, like time, space,
and energy, were
really the ones that
made a huge difference
in the price of goods
and the profitability
of companies.
Then in the information
economy, there's
sort of good services
and ideas that can't
be quantified or measured.
And those things are sort of--
since they can't be measured,
they're really more
about-- how do I say this?
They're really
more about stories
and the emotional connections
between those things.
So I think the more our economy
becomes more based on goods,
services, and ideas, things that
can't be quantified, measured,
or really managed
in the same way
that measurable
things are managed,
storytelling becomes
more important.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Just two
more questions here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wanted to get
your opinion on what
you think the story behind
"Mad Men" really means.
Like what is the main
message that the show is
trying to convey to the audience
through the journey of Don
Draper?
MALE SPEAKER: How does it end?
JOSH WELTMAN: You know, I
couldn't possibly answer that.
It's so different being
inside the eye of the storm
and working to put it together.
And I think it's really best if
people like me who are in there
leave it up to other people
to get what they get.
Sometimes I got what
Matt got, and sometimes I
didn't get what the
writers got, or I got
something completely different.
I mean, I'm just like you.
When I see it on TV, it's
like, oh my god, you know?
It sure doesn't feel
when it's put together,
and you're looking at
it, like it did when
you were trying to make it.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Perhaps a different
way to ask the question
is, what has his journey
meant for you personally
over the time that
you've worked on it?
JOSH WELTMAN: Oh, it's been just
fantastic to go with him on it.
I got to find out so much
about so many smart people.
And it was like a graduate
course in human behavior.
And to see-- to work on
anything that successfully
connects with a lot of people
is just satisfying in every way.
That's great, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Last
question for you, Josh.
We're at a tech company.
And you talk about tech
companies in the book.
You say that they fall prey to
throwing things over the wall.
And you actually mention
Google, which I love.
JOSH WELTMAN: Sorry.
MALE SPEAKER: No, it's great.
You actually mention the first
product I worked on here.
What do tech companies do when
they throw it over the wall?
What does that mean?
JOSH WELTMAN: The first time
I heard the phrase "throw it
over the wall" was when I was
Creative Director on Microsoft.
And what that meant
was bringing a product
to market because you
can, without necessarily
thinking about why or how you're
going to get people to buy it.
It's making it--
I'm sorry, bringing
it to market because
you can make it,
rather than bringing it to
market because you think
you can make people buy it.
So without considering that,
sometimes things fall flat.
It doesn't really--
MALE SPEAKER: How does a tech
company make people buy it?
How do you create that itch?
JOSH WELTMAN: I think
a high tech company--
I think the hardest thing, or
the most important thing to do,
is to keep control of the
metaphor, the metaphor being
sort of what it's like,
what the product is
like in the real world.
You know, IBM spent
a lot of money 10,
15 years ago
advertising e-Business.
e-Business was the metaphor.
It was the idea of
business done online.
None of the machines or the
software that allowed business
to be done online
really existed.
So the money was
spent so that IBM
would be the company that
controlled what it meant
to do business online
by showing people
a story, a fiction of
what it looked like when
so and so in Poland could
create a cheese shop
and post i6 and get an order
from someone in-- before any
of this could actually happen.
You had to create
that Tomorrowland,
that vision of the future,
that that's where we're going.
MALE SPEAKER: Did Google
ever do this, do you think?
JOSH WELTMAN: Yeah.
I think Google did it.
I was telling you the
story of the first time
I heard that-- Google did it
when they came up with the name
Google, because I can
remember like it was yesterday
the first time I heard
somebody say, in an agency,
go Google that.
I didn't know what they meant.
I thought they could have
been telling me go fuck myself
or something like that.
I mean, what do you
mean, go Google it?
And when they said,
you know, there's
this thing on the Internet
that'll answer any question,
it made me very curious to
find out more about that,
because suddenly there was
someone in the office who
had a tool that I didn't have.
They had an edge.
They had all the
answers in the world.
MALE SPEAKER: An enthymeme.
JOSH WELTMAN: Yeah.
And I had to go
and check that out.
And it was having a word
for a product and a service
that had never existed before.
And calling it something that
I'd never heard before that
made me absolutely have
to scratch that itch.
I couldn't allow there
to be another person
in the agency who knew
about this valuable thing,
or wonderful thing that
I didn't know about.
So yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And you
scratched a couple times a day,
I take it.
JOSH WELTMAN: Yeah, lots.
MALE SPEAKER: Josh
Weltman's first book,
"Seducing Strangers."
Available in the back.
It's a great read.
Josh, thanks for
coming to Google.
JOSH WELTMAN: Absolutely.
Thanks for having me.